we're only in quite a small space here
but the mapping technology will cover
much much larger areas we can do whole
buildings we can do mine systems all
sorts of things so we're the curious in
bristol it's big science museum this is
a map we built using the robot we
navigated the robot around using the
same mapping device we can then build up
the whole map of this whole area if we
wanted to we could then send the robot
out autonomously to wander around in
this space the risk assessment says that
really we can only operate in a
controlled space so here you can see
we've got some barriers we've got we've
got david here who's helping us control
the space and so that means that people
who come into the space know what
they're doing
in general we should be two meters away
from the robot when the motors are
engaged that means we can't just send it
out autonomously into this space it
would be able to navigate around people
safely just as it can around other
obstacles the robot is quite powerful so
if people weren't paying attention it
would also be a risky interaction so
yeah we can't just send it out we've
done stuff in the past we've got other
robots mobile robots that are safety
rated they have big rubber bumpers you
just don't do it with spot well not yet
anyway one day maybe
so we've got a boston dynamic spot robot
and the interesting thing for us is the
payload on top
so
if you see a spot without any payload on
there then you know people are not doing
too much autonomous with it the stuff on
top is what we use to make it autonomous
on the front we've got what we call a
frontier device so this is a kind of
integrated unit on the top you've got a
lidar that's giving you a laser
measurement so 360 degrees around the
robot in kind of a cone so you're always
seeing a kind of a range of measurements
around there on the front we've got a
real sense intel real sense camera that
is used to track the motion of the robot
frame by frame using the images it's
also got an inertial measurement unit in
there imu so we can track a little bit
of how the device moves and this box is
an intel nut what does nook stand for is
it uh it's the next unit of computation
so it's an intel design of kind of a
small motherboard kind of small form
factor pc so all the computation all the
algorithms we're using to build 3d maps
to plan robot missions it's all running
inside that box
and we've got effectively an ethernet
cable and a power cable that's all
that's running out of the robot over
here we've got a mesh wi-fi network so
when we go autonomy and we want to go
beyond line of sight we can drop a
breadcrumb trail of wi-fi repeaters that
we're able to use from that what we're
doing with the robot and the whole
payload is looking at autonomous
inspection missions so the aim is to
take a robot like this
map a facility and then have the robot
autonomously repeat a mission where that
mission might be to
take some images of different locations
to measure for example radiation been
working part of a radiation project or
do gas detection so anywhere you want a
robot to monitor a large scale facility
we put these things together to achieve
that kind of those kind of missions on
the screen here we've got the
visualization of the the software the
robot's running and so as i said what we
want to do is build a large
map of the area and we're going to
perform autonomous inspection in that so
if you're in a site you typically need
two things to uh be able to to do that
you need the 3d representation of the
environment and you also need a mission
planning system to be able to task the
robot so our kind of standard tasks are
go there do that go to the fire door
check whether it's open or closed for
example so you can see these two things
on the screen these white dots are the
returns from the laser or the lidar
that's showing us what the robot can see
but that's also kind of the the starting
point of the 3d map we've only just
turned the robot on so it's quite sparse
and that's going to get denser and
denser as the robot walks around and
gets more points then you've got this
graph here that's going to be our
mission system so when i say go there do
that there is going to be one of these
nodes so it's a location the robot can
go to
so what we're going to demonstrate is we
can build both of these representations
at once online and we're going to do
that by actually giving the robot
missions the mission will be to go just
walk to a location so my awesome
assistant mihal here is going to send
the robot to a node it's going to select
it on the interface and then the robot
will walk off to that location
as it's doing that it's checking the
space around it
and in that space what it's doing is
it's looking for extra areas where it
can add the nodes to build that graph up
it's also continually building the the
3d representation around it so if you
look back at the screen you can see that
it's denser here now than it was before
so more points we've got more graph and
the robot is just gradually walking
around building up the representation
so at the moment the movement across the
graph is autonomous but the the
locations the robot's going to we're
picking those manually
so we could do this fully autonomously
we could just let the robot loose it
would continually build up a map or you
could even do it fully manual so you can
pick up a joystick and drive the robot
around so this is now the mapping stage
as complete as we need it to be in a
space like this we can't go very far so
the robot's done
and then we can switch from this sort of
exploration mode we can switch into
missions
so what we'll do now is meehau can
switch the system into a mode where
instead of us just driving it around we
can just give it a list of tasks so the
task will be to go to particular
locations and perform inspections
and usually we'd have some kind of
inspection payload so we're working with
a company called createtech as part of a
large-scale collaboration around nuclear
robotics and so we might carry a gamma
sensor to measure radioactivity at
particular locations we've also done
visual inspections of oil and gas
facilities this is the kind of complete
map
this is about as as good as we're going
to get given this small area i haven't
had much space to move around in so
so that's a point cloud that yeah the
lidar's giving you
yeah so you know we can see
various bits outside the glass as well
but most of it's kind of constrained yes
because there's glass walls
and what we're doing is when we're
querying the space we're not using this
representation it's quite hard to query
so when i say query we're saying is
there a bunch of space where i could put
a node so instead of querying the point
cloud we put this in something called an
octo map which is a kind of a
voxel-based representation so it's like
pixels but in 3d and they're a lot
coarser and you can use those to quickly
look up
how much space is occupied how much free
space is there so that allows us to do
faster queries than you would you would
on the the point cloud in fact this is
it thanks this is kind of lego minecraft
uh of this room yeah this is the
minecraft version of the world these are
on the order of 10 centimeter
cubes
and we use those
to
basically ray trace through the
environment
and we have a small bounding box around
the ray so that we can
actually capture
you know if there's a small hole in the
environment we don't want to poke
through that hole
we want to make sure that we capture
all of the kind of environmental hazards
as it were in the in the projections
that we're doing so that we don't place
nodes in places where
uh
we wouldn't want to go with the robot if
you know exactly where you want the
robot to go you take the 3d map and then
you manually annotate it with the points
in this case we're doing it entirely
well
the graph is built autonomously
using that that lego representation so
you say are there any lego bricks in
this area if not then i'll pop a node in
there because i can move there and
you've configured how big the robot is
and therefore whether it'll fit yeah so
all i have to do is basically i'm
selecting
a node in the interface
and when i click it
stuff happens in the system in the
background basically looking up to the
closest nodes to this point
and then we compute i think what was the
floyd warsaw so we're doing yeah
shortest path through the graph to reach
the target location and what you'll see
is basically the yellow arrows are
showing the policy that we're using to
traverse the graph
which is if i'm at this node
what path would i need to take to get to
the goal location and this applies to
every single node in the whole graph so
i'll send it to node i think that's node
8 and you'll see that the arrows in the
graph will change to all point towards
node a well the policy gives the row one
action for every location in its world
because we often do this in dynamic
environments or with uncertainty so that
means the robot even though it's trying
to get to one location it might
accidentally end up at another location
if it avoids an obstacle that it doesn't
know is there then it needs to know what
action to perform when it reaches that
state so that's why in in the
visualization you'll see actions from
all the locations not just the shortest
path this is kind of the manual autonomy
stage as it were so i've been selecting
the points that we're going to to build
up the
um the map that we're using for
localization
um but as nick said we have
kind of the second stage which is the
auto the full autonomy stage where we
specify actions at specific nodes
and we can then perform
visual inspections or whatever else we
can do right here we don't actually have
an inspection payload so
basically what we have to do is use some
kind of body motions to indicate right
when we're here we would do something
what you'll see is the robot will be
moving its body when it reaches a
particular location the reason we move
the body is because when you're doing an
inspection typically the sensors are
mounted on the front or the back of the
robot you need to position the robot's
body relative to the target so these are
all um
actions you we would use in practice
sometimes you want to look high you want
to look low you want to look around a
corner so you'll see all of those kind
of actions deployed by the robot all
right i'm going to start a mission in a
second
i've entered some
relevant names into our
text file which we then pause and
basically send the mission this is
definitely not a user interface this is
a development tool we've built
information what is what is the
development now environment this is just
a vim editor that i'm using to edit
things i'm connected through this wi-fi
extender to the robot so i'm i'm using
vim because that's the easiest thing
that i know to use but i'm using i'm
using emacs keybindings in pycharm so i
mean we could also talk a little bit
about the various software tools we're
using okay should we do that after we
watch it
i've specified a couple of nodes which
are reasonably separated within our
environment
and it's reached the final the first
node so now we'll just do a little body
roll
orienting its cameras better to get a
better image of the target
or looking quizzically at the door
that's also
and then it will re-route to the next
node in its mission
so i
after i send the mission
i'm not touching anything at all it's uh
it's doing everything fully autonomously
it's
really worth reinforcing that this is
all
on board the robot everything is running
on board the robot we are not giving any
commands we've just specified
where it should go and what it should do
there it's using the graph that was
built up earlier so it's got its map of
the world so it knows where it's safe to
move
it's got its gra it's topological graph
the network that's on the floor that
tells it where it should be moving
through the space all this autonomous
behavior is enabled by the payload on
the top so we talked through earlier the
lidar at the front we've got various
wi-fi connections running off it and
that's what you know if you see a spot
in a video or a show where there's
nothing on top
they're typical people using actively
not doing anything autonomous you need
that payload on top either to to enable
the capabilities here or to do something
when you're autonomous so it shows you
what you're doing with the platform
and why wouldn't you just cover an area
with sort of cctv cameras or something
why use a robot like this oh it's a good
question so
for some applications fixed sensing is
better if if the world is static the
sensors are cheap
i think robots often occupy this sweet
spot where you've got a reasonably
expensive
sensing payload and you need to get it
into places where you can't continually
monitor so for us
large facilities where you want to just
image certain areas but you can't get
humans in there
places where you want to see around
corners um all sorts of places where you
put the robots in um
i think the other thing
we're looking at is really the long-term
angle so what we'd like to do next is
have a robot-like spot that lives in a
facility and it has a sort of daily
routine a to-do list it gets up in the
morning it walks around and checks the
same things does the same inspection
tasks or intervention tasks at certain
locations and then because you're using
a robot you get very repeatable data
very repeatable observations
from those sensors you're using there
people often feel they're being observed
if you've got cameras everywhere
people behave differently if a robot
walks up in the robot you know the robot
is the thing carrying the camera
it's kind of it shows you that this is
the thing doing the inspection you're
not being monitored constantly you've
just got this robot that's doing the
observations the vast majority of the
code that we have running is running
using the ros middleware system
so it's basically a message passing
system which allows us to
communicate over multiple computers so
my computer is connected to a roscore
which is basically the system that is
kind of running the whole robot that's
living on the knock that we have inside
the payload
and basically we use a subscriber
publisher thing so we're sending
messages regularly to specific topics
and we're using that information
on
other nodes which live in the system
separate to
map nodes there are ros nodes which run
components of the system maybe a good
example is the lidar there's a driver
that's reading the data off the lidar
that data is then being published into
the ros system in fact we could we could
see it on the screen so what you're
getting is that the the data is being
turned into a data type it's being
published on the network you can
subscribe to it on the robot to do some
processing on board or when we run the
visualizations that's what we're doing
we're subscribing
to the data streams that are coming off
the robot and then you could use them on
the computer to measure things you can
also visualize them so the whole system
is based on this topic infrastructure
and that allows you to do things kind of
quickly add new components reuse things
and the other advantage of a component
based middleware is you can write
components in different languages ross
stands for the robot operating system
and it's that operating system element
which means translating between
languages and allowing multiple
components to run so a lot of the
mission planning side we've written is
written in python a lot of the mapping
side is written in c plus plus but we
use ross to make sure that these things
can talk to each other uh it kind of as
the robot's running it's like the robot
slack is it yeah absolutely you've got a
chat so no it's it's exactly like slack
well not exactly like that that's a
complete exaggeration
it's similar so you've got channels the
channels are topics the topics have a
name which describes the purpose so you
might have front front left camera would
be the the topic and then it just has a
data type in this case would be an image
data type and if you want to get
messages about the front left camera you
join that channel
no it's a it's a great analogy
then you can see
that the depth still works but it's much
much worse than it was before and that's
because now
we only have the two cameras we're just
doing the best we can with what we've
got
so this idea of probabilistic robotics
has been the dominant approach to
program robots at the moment